Você sabia que o óleo de coco pode fazer
Maravilhas pela sua digestão e pela
absorção de nutrientes essenciais como é
o caso de vitaminas e minerais ele tem
um papel facilitador na absorção de
vitaminas lipossolúveis que se dissolvem
em gordura além de cálcio e magnésio
quando combinarmos o óleo de coco com os
ácidos grassos ômega-3 a eficiência
desses ácidos ômega-3 duplica porque ele
ajuda o ômega-3 a ficar pronto para ser
melor digerido e utilizado pelo nosso
corpo outra dica que o uso do Óleo de
coco junto com a piperina extraído da
penta preta podem auxiliar na absorção
da curcumina um poderoso composto
encontrado no açafrão de acordo com o
estudo o óleo de coco é tão fácil de
digerir que pode até mesmo aliviar a
pressão sobre o pâncreas e também
melhorar os sintomas da doença da
vesícula biliar